it's time for our scene an unseen
segment where we expose the big cultural
stories of the day like wire researchers
calling a childhood game dehumanizing
and oppressive and if you have kids we
have a warning about a new show pushing
dangerous boundaries joining us now with
all the details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor New York Times bestselling
author of will wilder the amulet of
power all right Raymond first I need to
get this warning out about this latest
HBO show tell us
yeah well it's called euphoria lore and
it's targeted to teens it builds itself
as an edgy true-to-life depiction of
growing up today but in reality it's a
boundary-pushing graphic sex acts nudity
violence crazy drug use among young
people it's sort of the old girls show
on crack the show features former Disney
star zendaya in what is a play for
tweens and high school kids this show is
so graphic I really can't even describe
the events here Laura but one cast
member was so disgusted by the content
and the sexual adventures that were
introduced into the script he walked off
the set HBO's bosses were concerned
about the male nudity in the show and if
you know if they're concerned about it
you know this must be bad what my
problem is as a parent you're pushing
boundaries and you're establishing is
normative these deviant sexual behaviors
transgenderism gender fluidity
ridiculous drug use and passing it off
as normative now is Sam Levinson who
Barry Levinson's son who created the
show this guy spent time in and out of
rehab up until he was 16 of course this
is normal for him living in elite
Hollywood life I think I got rid of HBO
after The Sopranos you would meet both I
just I was like yep oh my god it's just
not something I cared it well pay for
I'm not gonna pay extra for it and I'm
not going to allow it in my home well
this show we don't watch almost any TV
she's beyond pushing the envelope it is
so far there's an agenda and they're
pushing this agenda we're gonna be
hitting this in the coming weeks and
months yeah all right speaking of bad
behavior
people are chart charging in the u.s.
women's soccer team with being poor
sports after the World Cup victory over
Thailand this week what's going on look
this is the largest margin Laura in
World Cup history 13 to nothing but some
commentators and a few anchors thought
the US team was gratuitous in the way
they celebrated after each point was
scored now late in the game they were
still hugging and cheering and and
encouraging each other I mean a goal
like nine and ten right well they
thought it went overboard and and you
know my problem is this whether you lose
or you win
grace matters in sports and let's face
it we have not seen a lot of examples of
this you remember Serena Williams last
year yelling at that that coat of the
ref she was fined hundreds of thousands
of dollars you've got you've got
football players who go overboard when
they you know when they make a goal or
when they we need to teach grace now all
of that said I don't think this came
across the line at all they pushed it to
the limit as one of their own members
said you play to the whistle blows
that's how you play the game
particularly at this level and wide
scored matters and the way this is cut
this is done in the World Cup
we were just in Paris it was all
starting a u.s. women's team is unreal
but they are so town sold the Thailand -
yeah when they were out I think that's
brutal lose by that that much but maybe
not put it in their face all right I
think what else is happening Oh
Vancouver researchers in a new study
Laura are declaring dodgeball in phys ed
classes dehumanizing they say it harms
their peers they also say it can be an
outlet for aggression that leads to
exploitation powerlessness and violence
and it just hurts the cruelty of it
Laura the cruelty you've got to learn
the five DS of dodge ball dodge duck dip
dive and dodge
Shoei they learned by dodging balls that
are thrown at us or that's what the sack
of reference is for
if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball any other questions
I love dodgeball now we learn that James
Corden's Late Show will be hosting a
transatlantic dodgeball showdown next
week in the UK Laura guests will be
leading the American team you see you
there Michelle I bet she's there she is
so in the spirit of Let's Move Laura
it's your turn to move back it up back
it up gotcha gotcha do you look at it I
think I was usually picked first for dog
oh I'll bet I was the guy I would get
behind the big guys and wait it out
battery off dodgeball was of it by the
way it was smart idea to invite
Stephanopoulos in of the Oval do you
know they gave him two days with the
president Iowa the Neil works is a
sit-down in the Rose Garden a big
special on ABC I don't know why they did
we went all the way across the ocean got
15 we got an hour we enjoyed our great
15 minutes yeah but he gets two days all
right
two days all right well we'll see how
that works